what's going on guys this is Rob and
before we get too far into this this
vlog Atari kid and Ernest Brown how long
do you guys plan on bickering back and
forth over whether or not the Scarlet
Witch is going to be in x-men Days of
Future past he's not like killing me
with that every time I get onto YouTube
it's always one notification and it's
always yep nope it's always one of those
two things and you guys are just going
back and forth and back and forth
alright here's the answer to the
question yes the Scarlet Witch is going
to appear in the x-men Days of Future
past but she's gonna be like three or
four years old she's not gonna be very
old and she's not going to appear in the
same capacity as she will be in the
Avengers age of Ultron does this mean is
she's gonna be using her powers probably
not she's someone just appearing as a
cameo because she's the sister of
Quicksilver and that's probably about it
so question answered let's move on so
the other thing is actually a couple
things that I want to talk about in this
in this video blog one I'm not going to
be uploading any videos until probably
next Thursday and the reason why is
because I'm gonna be out of town all
this week and into the weekend for my
dad's birthday and then I probably won't
be back in time to create another Marvel
request Monday video for next Monday so
the next video that I'll upload will be
the video on Thursday where I'll talk
about whatever it was whatever it is
that I'm I feel like talking about I'm
not really sure who I want to talk about
yeah but I'm kind of leaning towards
like Nick Fury I don't know if you guys
want to see a video on him or not he's
he's a really really old character and
Marvel comic he's been around for a long
long time but I'm actually getting over
a cold I know if you guys could tell
that or not I've had the damn thing for
are we gonna have like two weeks maybe I
should go to the doctor I don't know but
um anyway so the other thing is is that
we're at almost 2500 subscribers right
now 25 let's say that said that out loud
with me 2500 subscribers that's nuts
that's crazy
I never expected us to get to 2500
subscribers to be honest I mean three
weeks ago we had 500 subscribers we've
grown almost exponentially and again
this is I I say this all because of you
guys I give myself very little credit
here all I do is make videos I upload
videos about Marvel Comics you guys are
the ones that chimed in with questions
you guys are the ones to tell your
friends to post them on websites and
stuff like that
this is all because of you guys our
growth is 100% you guys so again I
really you know thank you guys thank you
so much because you guys have been the
ones that have really helped this
channel grow the other thing is that
I've seen a lot of questions recently
people asking stuff you know who's
stronger Thanos or Galactus or something
like that and because of how fast our
channel is growing I'm not going to be
able to answer every single question
that somebody asked in the comment
section and I'm probably not gonna do a
video on every single question I mean I
may dedicate a day where I take like the
top 10 questions that people ask I just
answer them and it might just be like a
five-minute video or something like that
but for right now I'm looking to you
guys who know a lot about Marvel Comics
those of you who were part of my youtube
channel and who were subscribers that
know a lot about Marvel so that if
somebody gets on and they asked the
question you know what was the first
comic that Spiderman appeared and you
can say it was amazing fantasy 15 you
know you guys can answer these questions
for people that they have and you guys
can chime in and pick up the slack that
I just don't have time to pick up or
that I just you know can't pick up
because there's so many questions that
come in all the time so you know if you
guys can be my frontline guys if you
guys could be the ones that get in there
you know and answer questions you know
and and help people understand that this
is a group effort that it's me providing
videos and you guys are doing just as
much work as I am in terms of making
sure that people are informed and making
sure that people have answers to the
questions that they're asking and that
would be fantastic
that would be amazing so um the other
thing is this I know a lot of you guys
have probably noticed that I did some
testing on live streaming only the last
week or so and the whole reason for that
is because I'm thinking about taking
like one week out of the month like the
last week of every month and devoting
that to myself then the reason why is
because you know I have a full-time job
as it is right now in addition to doing
YouTube doing these videos it kind of
equates out to be like two full-time
jobs just because as soon as I finished
Marvel request Monday
I'm almost immediately back in getting
ready and preparing for the next video
on Thursday getting all my stuff
together and getting all the comic book
panels together and all that kind of
good stuff so it's like non-stop on this
whole YouTube thing and so in an effort
to keep myself from getting burned out
and an effort date to keep this from
feeling like a job and keeping it fun
and keeping it interesting and bringing
you guys really good quality stuff
I think I'm gonna take one week out of
the year and I'm not gonna upload
anything Marvel related I'm just gonna
play like video games I'm gonna play
like BioShock Infinite or I'm gonna play
you know Lego Marvel's which looks
amazing and like the Ultimate Alliance
and and stuff like that because I think
it's just fun to livestream things like
that I'm not gonna upload any video
games it's like commentaries or anything
god knows I did call duty commentating
and i'ma tell you as it sucks I mean I
love Call of Duty don't get me wrong
mana 1 for 2 was the best Call of Duty
game and I'd love to livestream that
game but we're not gonna do commentaries
we're not gonna upload you know six or
seven minute videos of me playing
Bioshock talking about stuff and that's
not going to happen this is a comic book
channel and all the videos that get
uploaded to my channel on a routine
basis are going to be comic book related
materials so you know don't believe that
because I'm gonna be taking a week to
livestream video games that I'm somehow
preparing to transition over to a video
game channel that's not going to happen
which is ironic because I'm actually
partnered with TGN the game Network a
gaming network whatever it is which is
like a video game partnership Network I
don't know why but you know at the very
least it would give me exposure all that
kind of good stuff unless I think that
that's a really good idea for me I think
it's something that I really want to do
because I want to keep things fresh and
I feel like you know if this becomes
boring to me or if this becomes
monotonous and it turns into something
that I don't like the quality of my
videos is going to reflect my dislike of
that and so I'm not gonna be bringing
you guys really good quality videos and
and I've heard you guys talking about
here what you guys are saying and a lot
of you guys are saying that what I'm
doing here on my youtube channel is the
best that you've ever seen when it comes
to this kind of thing which is
incredibly complimentary and it's very
humbling you know to me to know that I'm
on the forefront of videos like these
but um you know I want to make sure that
this standard that I've created for the
quality of my videos remains that it
doesn't change them it doesn't go away
and so in order for me to do that I need
to be able to make sure that I feel like
this isn't becoming a job and then I'm
having fun and I'm enjoying myself so
with that being said uh yeah I'm gonna
bring this to an end I'll see you guys
in a couple weeks
and yeah
peace now this is a very iconic comic
book panel in comic books and the reason
why is because this confirms that almost
all of the comic book characters in
marvel that we have come to know and
love have been killed Susan storm Johnny
Storm Cyclops Jean Grey Nightcrawler
all these characters are dead now Kitty
Pryde continues to explain to us that in
this time of the original x-men there
are only four that remained there are
wool brain storm Colossus and Kitty
Pryde herself